voilà donc pour le résumé de la faire
alors ce matin nous avons également
rencontré jacqueline denis la
journaliste qui à moins d'être très
longue et très difficile interview de
gagner le monde ce matin
ce qui est certain c'est que les déchets
de seveso ont franchi la frontière
française à vintimille 10 septembre 1989
puis ils se sont dirigés vers marseille
vers paris et ont abouti à saint quentin
où ils ont été dédouanés ils ont été
alors déchargé d'une usine de saint
quentin et ensuite nous en sommes
réduits aux hypothèses alors l'étranger
nous n'avons trouvé aucune trace de ces
douaniers expliquer cette hausse
garantit l'immersion mais ce serait tout
à fait illégal ensuite alors nous en
sommes réduits peut-être une
incinération
dans une cimenterie d'autres centrales
thermiques mais généralement ceux
d'établissements n'accepte pas les
déchets toxiques de style à l'adresse de
la possibilité de l'enfouissement dans
une décharge sur le territoire français
en espérant que ce ne soit pas dans une
décharge sauvage ou dans une ancienne
mine à la tablée des charges autorisées
il y en a une qui est dans le
département de la vendée qui dont 10%
des parts appartiennent aux courtiers
qui s'est chargée du transport des
déchets il y en a une autre également
dans le nord de la france non loin de
saint quentin et il y en a également une
autre entre nîmes et arles qui reste
muet connaissez vous n'avez aucune
preuve que ces déchets soient sur l'être
sur le territoire français je n'ai bien
sûr aucune preuve
simplement je n'ai pas non plus la
preuve du contraire et il ya surtout
aucun papier sauf que le cas la
cargaison est sortie du territoire
français
que dit le gouverneur
le sujet est bien le gouvernement
français ne veut pas démenti
rester sur le territoire français
puisque la société hoffmann-la roche et
le gouvernement italien ne répond pas et
disent ne pas savoir où sont les déchets